ونذهب الان الى البرازيل حيث عدد الهدوء
نسبيا الى شوارع العاصمه البرازيليه بعد
ليله عاصفه شهدت اقتحام مناصري الرئيس
البرازيلي السابق جايرب بول سونارو مبنى
الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا وقصر بلاغته
الرئاسيه قبل ان تستعيد القوه الامنيه
سيطره على هذه المباني بعد التدخل الامني
طارق رئيس البرازيلي لويز اين سيولدا
سيلفا قام غداه هذه الاحداث بزياره تفقديه
لما قرات الفروع الثلاثه الحكوميه في
العاصمه كما استانف عمله في مكتبه في
العاصمه برازيليه
[موسيقى]
وبعد عوده الهدوء بات الشغل الشاغل للرئيس
الجديد معاقبه المتورطين بعد هذا التجاوز
الخطير وهو ما تعهد به لويس لولاد سيلفا
رفقه رؤساء الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا في
بيان نشره الرئيس على صفحته في تويتر اذان
دا سيلفا في البيان المشترك هذه الاعمال
التي وصفها البيان بالارهابيه مشددا على
ضروره معاقبه المتورطين هذا واشار وزير
العدل فلافيودينو الى اعتقال نحو 200 شخص
في اعقاب هذه الاحداث لحد الان
فيما وصف وزير الاتصالات البرازيليه
الاحداث الاخيره في بلاده ومهاجمه مقر
حكوميه بانها
اش من الاعتداء على مبنى الكابتول في
الولايات المتحده
ما حدث في البرازيل اشد خطوره مما حدث في
مبنى الكابيتول في الولايات المتحده هناك
كان لدينا هجوم على المقر الحكوميه لكن
بسبب الاستجابه السريعه تمكننا من استعاده
المباني الثلاثه ونعمل على عوده الامور
الى طبيعتها في الكونغرس والقصر وسيكون كل
شيء جاهزا في غضون ساعه قليله